pete davidson is wearing his heart on
his sleeve or should we say shirt just
days after he and kim kardashian called
it quits yep
here's pete seemingly sulking while on
the wizard set in australia and while
his face probably reflects his mood his
t-shirt is pretty telling too if you
take a closer look pete's sweatshirt
gets right to the point i feel like
now pete has yet to break his silence on
his split from kim but for now that
message kinda says it all now are you
gonna kiss me or not
i sure am jasmine
the former couple seemed to be going
strong after they first hit it off in
october during kim's debut on saturday
night live
but nine months later things came to a
screeching halt so what ended it well a
source told e.t the spark between kim
and pete faded plus they struggled to
stay connected with their busy work
schedules what's your favorite thing
about him um
he's just super genuine
and it's just really fun to just hang
out and do nothing and
watch tv and just do nothing
that's my favorite thing yeah and i love
the chemistry that kim and him have
together it's really sweet thought you
said the chemistry it's like okay
chemistry
chemistry yeah our source says they had
tons of chemistry and still do but the
mom of four wants to get back on the
market and date
kim wasn't feeling like she was willing
to settle down with him just yet
pete is has got to be literally the best
human being i've ever met like the best
heart we're told kim still adores pete
and wants to remain friends one thing
she likes a lot about the comedian how
different he is from her estranged
husband kanye west quote she felt like
pete was the extreme opposite of kanye
and it was good for her god sent me from
that crash
just so i could beat pete davis
meanwhile months after yay first took
aim at pete the rapper is now
celebrating kim's breakup
yay posted this now deleted image to
instagram a fake cover of the new york
times with a fake headline like all i
can do is control how i react to
something i can't control
what other people do how he treats me
kim reportedly isn't happy about yay's
meme which may explain why it's no
longer up on his page
but just days before she showed her
support for his new yeezy sunglasses
launch posing with their daughters
chicago and north in the futuristic
sunnies
you just gotta roll with it
as for keith things may be over but
we'll have to stay tuned for season two
of the kardashians just tune in because
you never know what's gonna happen
pete's set to make his debut and things
may even get a little spicy life is good
i have a new boyfriend i'm just having a
really good time babe yeah do you want
to shower with me really quick
[Music]